REVIEW WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING IN RESPONSE THE
CUPBOARD NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC WE MUST ALL
OF US WE MUST LIMIT OR
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
ANARKY'S COVERING GUIDELINES.
AND IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
NORMAL PRACTICES. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR MEETINGS HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING SENATOR STERN
IS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
SENATOR CAN YOU IDENTIFY
YOURSELF NOW AND IF YOU HAVE
SUPPORT STAFF WITH YOU CAN YOU
PLEASE IDENTIFY THEM AS WELL.
YES THEY CAN SHARE- CENTER
STERN IN THE IT JUST OFFICES
TWENTY WITH MY DISTRICT J. WILL
ENOUGH ROOM. GREAT THANK YOU.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE READ. FOR THE
OF FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AND I
AND I'M SURE YOU ALL KNOW THOSE
OF YOU PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
THAT MUTING YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS GREATLY HELPS US
ELIMINATE ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
AND WHEN YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE
RECOGNIZED. PLEASE USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM- AND OF COURSE WHEN I
CALL YOU MAKE SURE TO HIT ON
MUTE. SO THAT WE CAN HEAR YOU
WHEN YOU SPEAK- A PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC%
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. THE TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTINCT DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY FOR THE WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL USE THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE THE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE ARE
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. BUT I WILL ALSO THREE
TWO NOW IT IS TODAY'S NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT NINE THREE SEVEN
THREE FOUR THREE. NOW PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY YOU ALSO
SHOULD MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY. WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING HEARING
AS IS CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE OUR HEARING
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IT IS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGY SOMETIMES CREATE LAG
TIMES AND- OTHER ISSUE SO.
PRESHEAF YOU'RE BEING
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. NOW
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S SEE I
DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM YET NO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM YET SO WE
ARE GOING TO BEGIN THE HEARING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE- AND THE
REASON WILL DO THAT IS BECAUSE
I AM AWARE THAT THERE ARE AT
LEAST TWO OTHER COMMITTEES OR
AT LEAST ONE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEETING AT THE PRESENT TIME.
AND SO SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
MAYBE IN THAT COMMITTEE AND I'M
SURE THEY WILL COME DOWN AS
SOON AS THEY'RE ABLE- SO. WE
WILL- AS I SAID BEGIN THE
HEARING AS SUBCOMMITTEE AND WE
ONLY HAVE ONE BILL TODAY IT IS
AB EIGHTY SEVEN AND IT IS A
CLEAN UP BILL TO AN ACTION WE
TOOK LAST YEAR AND IT IS A
REGARDING THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT.
SO HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE A
RELATIVELY- STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
SIMPLE HEARING. AB EIGHTY SEVEN
MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES
NECESSARY TO EFFECTUATE THE
REALIGNMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUVENILE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AS APPROVED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACTIONS-
WHAT THE CLEAN UP ALLOWS IS FOR
COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH SECURE.
YOUTH TREATMENT FACILITIES FOR
YOUTH WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
COMMITTED TO THE STATE'S
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
AND THE REASON WE ARE NEEDING
TO DO THIS ACTION IS WE WANT TO
ENSURE APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS
AND AVOID YOUTH POTENTIALLY
BEING COMMITTED TO THE ADULT
SYSTEM- WHICH COULD TAKE PLACE
IF WE DON'T ACT NOW- IF WE
DELAY ACTION. WE WILL HEAR THE
BILL AND ALLOW MEMBERS TO ASK
QUESTINS PRIOR TO TAKING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEN WE WILL
VOTE AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
BEFORE I TURN TO THE
PRESENTATION FOR AB EIGHTY
SEVEN MISTER VICE CHAIR DO YOU
HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS NO
JUST PROJECT DEVELOPMENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR- NIELSEN
VICE CHAIR. SO LET US BEGIN
WITH THE PRESENTATION OF AB
EIGHTY SEVEN BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- BERMAN FINANCE
YOU'RE READY. THE MORNING GO
AHEAD. MORNING MADAMS VICE
CHAIR NEIL AND MY OF THE-
EREKLE WITH A OF FINE AND I
WILL PRESENTING ON AB SEVEN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE BILL.
BACKGROUND SB EIGHT THREE WHICH
WAS BUDGET- BILL FROM TWENTY
TWO BUDGET AT. REALIGNED THE
CARE SUPERB OF THE THAT HAVE.
SPECIFIED FROM ARE DIVISION OF
G. JUSTICE OR DG. COUNTIES
STARTING TO ONE THIS YEAR.
ISRAEL WILL ENABLE YOU TO
REMAIN IN THE COMMUNITY AND
STATE TO THE FAMILY WITH THE GO
OF AND- OUR- FOR JUSTICE AND
YOUTH. AND REDUCING UNIVERSITY.
AB SEVEN UP FOR. TODAY AN OF
FOLLOW ON TO S. B. TWENTY. AND
ADDRESS AREAS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO HELP. RELY OF TO
COUNTIES THIS. DJJ WE CLOSE
INTAKE A UNDERLINE OF THIS WITH
LIMITED EXCEPTION. AB EIGHTY
SEVENTH. THE D. WILL CLOSE. AND
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT ARE OF
DJJ TO NEARBY A TO BUY JAN OF
NEXT YEAR FOR THE TRANSFER OF
ANY REMAINING USE THAT WERE
UNABLE TO DISCHARGE PRIOR TO
THE CLOSURE OF DJJ. THIS BILL
IF THAT WISHES A FRAMEWORK FOR
SIX TREATMENT THIS A- FOR NEED
YOUTH THAT'S CONSERVE WITH THE
INTENT LANGUAGE SB TWENTY. IF
THAT'S AT LEAST A FULL. WILL
HAVE A STILL TO BE ABLE PER.
TREATMENT AND EDUCATE SPECIFIC
TO THEIR NEEDS. THE CIVIC LAID
THE BILL INCLUDES THE FINDINGS
THAT COURTS MUST MAKE IN ORDER
TO ASSIGN YOU TO THESE
FACILITIES. AND IF THE COURT
ORDERS YOU TO BE PLACED IN
SECURE FACILITY THE COURT MUST
RECEIVE REVIEW. AND APPROVE AN
INDIVIDUAL REHABILITATION PLAN
FOR THAT USE THAT IDENTIFIES
THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS AND THE
PROGRAMMING TREATMENT AND
EDUCATION. THAT WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE. TO THEM DURING THE
COURSE OF THEIR PLACEMENT. THE
BILL ALSO FROM THE CORE TO BE A
BILL. TO TRY YOU. THE SECURE.
TO LESS RESTRICTIVE FACILITY-
TO LESS RESTRICT PROGRAM. IF AN
ALTAR. PLACEMENT WITH- BETTER
SIR THAT YOU AND THAT YOU NEED.
FINALLY THE BILL PROPOSES OTHER
TECHNICAL AND G. THAT FROM CO
SECTION RELATED THE PRIOR DJJ.
COMMITMENT PROCESS. I'M NOT
CONCLUDE PRESENTATION I JOINED
WITH MY CO. ALLISON AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO AND ANY. FROM THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
ARMS WILL NOW OPEN. DISCUSSION
WITH. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CENTER
NIELSEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I DO NOT HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION. THEY DO
NOT WARRANT QUESTIONS. THE BILL
LAST YEAR IT WAS A FAILURE.
DISK CLEANUP. IS TRYING TO MAKE
SOMETHING BETTER THAT FAILED
LAST YEAR. IT ONLY FAILS IT
WORKS. THE ESSENCE OF THIS RE
ALIGNMENT OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. IS WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE PREVIOUS
ONES HAVE BEEN APPLYING. THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENT. I CALL IT THE
PUNCHES PILOT APPROACH THE
STATE IS ONE HANDS. OF WHAT
HERETOFORE BEEN RESPONSE AND
DUMPING IT. ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND ONE OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS THAT FAILS IN THIS.
THE WORD RECIDIVISM IS A JOKE.
THE ONLY REASON THAT THIS BILL
WILL BE FACT IN THE LAST BILL
LAST YEAR AFFECTED A DECLINE
RECIDIVISM IS THERE WILL BE NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ANYBODY WHO
CONTINUES A CRIMINOLOGY. SO FOR
THE NORD IT DIDN'T HAPPEN. AND
THEREFORE THEY DID NOT RECEIVE
A- IT REMOVES ALL ARE GREATLY
DIMINISHES THE FUNDAMENTAL ROLE
OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
REHABILITATION. WHY BECAUSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT DOES NOT HAVE
THE FACILITIES THE CAPABILITY
THE STAFF THE EXPERTISE. TO DO
THE JOB. THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
IN FACT THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT EVEN WAS INADEQUATE
FOR DECADES IN CALIFORNIA. I
THINK THAT IS BEEN ARGUABLE. IF
YOU WANT TO SUPPORT THE BILL J.
YOU REALLY DID SOMETHING GREAT.
FIVE BUT GO BACK AND TALK TO
YOUR COUNTY SUPERVISORS. YOUR
SHARE. THE POLICE CHIEFS THE
VICTIM'S BY THE WAY VICTIMS
NEVER GET ANY INPUT INTO THESE
KIND OF BILLS NOT THAT THEY'RE
NOT A PART OF THE DEAL THE
VICTIMS. THIS IS SOMETHING.
THAT ONLY ONE THING CAN FIX.
REPEAL LAST YEAR'S BILL. I URGE
IN THE INTEREST OF THE CITIZENS
THAT WE REPRESENT AND IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE JUVENILE
OFFENDERS WHO WILL NOT BE
HELPED BY THIS ILL FOUNDED
REGISTRATION. TO VOTE NO. I'M
BEFORE I CALL IN ANY OTHER
MEMBERS- WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
AND- COMMITTEE CONSULTANT YOU
PLEASE ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM FOR
US CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
SKINNER I'M HERE. SKINNER HERE
NIELSEN. YES IN HERE CABALLERO.
CORTESE CORTESE HERE. DOLLY THE
RUSSELL RATHER HERE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GROW GROWTH HERE
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HERE LIAM.
WHERE MCGUIRE WELL MCGUIRE HERE.
MELENDEZ MELINDA'S HERE MAN MAN
HERE NEWMAN. THE TROUBLE. PAN
CAN HERE STERN. STERN HERE
STERN HERE. STERN HERE BY
CASTING. WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED SO WE CAN CONTINUE
OUR DISCUSSION SENATOR DRAW SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- THE VAST
MAJORITY OF INCARCERATED YOUTH
ARE HELD IN COUNTY LEVEL
FACILITIES LAST YEAR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM WORKED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO FULLY RELYING
JUVENILE JUSTICE FOR THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE REMAIN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES INSTEAD OF BEING
HELD IN YOUTH PRISONS FAR AWAY.
FROM THE RESOURCES AND THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO HEAL
TRAUMA AND CHANGE THE COURSE OF
THEIR LIVES THIS WAS A MOMENT
OF HOPE. THERE WAS ALSO
RECOGNITION THAT WE HAD TO GET
IT RIGHT IT WOULD NOT BE EASY
WE NEEDED TO FIND ALTERNATIVES
FOR ALL YOUTH OFFENDERS.
FAILURE TO DO SO WOULD RESULT
IN MORE YOUNG PEOPLE BEING
TRIED AS ADULTS. AS A RESULT OF
OUR CAREFUL EFFORTS SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW AND IMPLEMENTED. A
THOUGHTFUL PLAN FOR CLOSING THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE BY
TRANSFERRING THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE CUSTODY TREATMENT AND
SUPERVISION OF YOU TO THE
COUNTIES. SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE
ALLOCATED SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
TO COUNTIES TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES AND IMPROVE THE
FACILITIES TO INCREASE LOCAL
CAPACITY TO SERVE OUR YOUTH. D.
D. J. J. INTAKE ENDS BEGINNING
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
BUT SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE
PROVIDED NO FINAL CLOSURE DATE.
THIS BILL AB AB SEVEN CLOSES
DJJ ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND REQUIRES THE
DIRECTOR OF DJJ. TO DEVELOP A
PLAN BY JANUARY SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOR THE TRANSFER OF
ANY REMAINING USE IN DJJ WERE
UNABLE. TO BE DISCHARGED OR
MOVED. LAST YEAR SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE CODIFIED
LEGISLATURE INTENT TO ESTABLISH
A SPECIAL DISPOSITIONAL TRACK
TO BE USED AS AN ALTERNATIVE.
TO ADULT COURT PROSECUTION FOR
HIGHER NEED YOUTH. AB EIGHTY
SEVEN ESTABLISHES SECURE YOU
TREATMENT FACILITIES FOR HIGH
NEED YOUTH OR FOURTEEN OR OLDER
AND HAVE BEEN SENTENCED TO THE
SPECIAL DISPOSITIONAL TRACK. IT
PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON HOW
COUNTIES WILL DO TO KATE HOUSE
AND FACILITATE SERVICES FOR
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE IT ALSO
REQUIRES A REHABILITATION PLAN.
TO HELP THEM ON THEIR PATH TO
LEADING MEANINGFUL LIVES AS
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
I'M FOCUSED ON OUR VISION FOR A
BETTER JUSTICE SYSTEM. I WILL
MAKE CERTAIN THE NEW OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY IS
ADEQUATELY STAFFED AND RESOURCE
STE SO THAT THROUGH RE
ALIGNMENT FROM THE CORRECTIONS
SYSTEM TO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES IS REALIZED. I CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THIS TRANSITION
FROM A SYSTEM THAT HAS BEEN
DAMAGING TO OUR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITIES TOWARD THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
HEALING RESTORATION AND TO
OPPORTUNITY FOR CHANGE. AND
GROWTH THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK
YOU- NEO COMMENTS BY. MEMBERS
IN ELSE SEVEN AT- I WANTED.
TALK AS GROVE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM I A FEW IF. YEAH. THE
BETTER. YES SO GIVEN THE SURE-
TIME. THAT COUNTY WOULD HAVE
BUILDER FOR SIX USE OF. WHICH I
UNDERSTOOD IS ABOUT YEARS WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF A COUNTY
ELECTED TO BUILD ONE BUT WAS
UNABLE TO COMPLETE THE
CONSTRUCTION BY DJ DAY'S FINAL
CLOSURE DATE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES I HAD TO TURN THAT
QUESTION OVER TO ALISON HEWITT
THANK YOU. I THINK YOU DEPART
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU FOR THE
CALL. I'M THERE'S A LOT OF
EXISTING THAT THERE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT TO LACI DICE THE
RESPONSE QUESTION I THINK IS
THAT THE COUNTY IS IN CERTAIN
CASE NAY A LOT TO USE X. IN.
FOR OF TIME AND IF THEY ARE CON.
KIND OF NEW FIRST- THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING WHERE THEY BE ABLE
TO RELY ON EXISTING. AND
FACILITIES IN PRO THAT THEY
COUNTIES ARE OCT NINETY AS I
COUNTIES ARE SERVED THE MATURE
OF YOU AND REALLY WHAT WE'RE AT
IS THAT A POPULATION OF THE
YOUTH AND ARE ON SENT TO JAIL
THAT WE NOW A REALLY ACCOUNT
SINCE. THERE WOULD BE KIND OF
AN UNDER OR ABILITY REALIZE ON
EXISTING IN FIRST FOR THE TIME
I. AND A WE HAVE THT THAT
DIGITAL LEGISLATION EACH THREE
SOME FUNDING TO SUPPORT WITHIN.
UNDERSTANDING THAT MIGHT TAKE
SOME BUT THERE'S NO WITH THE IT
JUST LETTER NOT TO FRONT OF YOU
RICK THE CAN TO SE TO NEW FOR
TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL AND THEN THERE'S ALSO. FOR
TO CONTRACT WITH OTHER I TOOK
SECURE YOU TREATMENT AS A
SERVICES THERE'S A NUMBER
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY FOR THE IN
THE IS TO PROVIDE FLEXIBLE TO
THE CAN TO MEET THESE FOR. OF
BOTH IN THE NEAR TERM AND THE
LONG TERM. THANK YOU FOR THAT
IS THERE ANOTHER PER. THAT THE
COURT WOULD BEGIN TO SAY ASIDE
CA OR UNTIL THE FIFTH WAS CAN.
OR INTO THE COW COULDN'T. A CO.
WITH THE OTHER. WITH ANOTHER IN
A THIS CALL TO TAKE THESE. I'M
AT RISK YOU. WE WOULDN'T BE IN
A POSITION TO KINDA SPEAK TO
NOT- I THINK THAT WOULD BE BAD.
OF A FOR JUDICIAL. OR HAPPY TO
THE CAR BACK AND SEE WE CAN PER
SOME FOR UP IF. HOW CAN I DON'T
KNOW WHO GONNA AND THIS SUMMER
HAVE A COUPLE MORE OKAY. TO THE
LAW. OF THE COUNTY WOULD NEED A
SIX TREAT THIS. OR CON. FOR SO.
BY FIRST TWENTY THREE. LIKE YOU
WOULD HAVE TO BE IN PLACE BY
THE COUNTY BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IS THAT CORRECT. I
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE FULL I'M NOT
A 100% SURE I KNOW THAT
ESSENTIALLY. YOU WITH WILL BE
REALIGNED TO THE COUNTY
STRTING JULY FIRST. AND SO THE
BILL IS PROVISIONED AROUND
PROVIDING SECURE YOUTH.
FACILITIES OR NOT FRAMEWORK.
FOR THE JULY ONE REALIGNMENT
BECAUSE COUNTIES NEED TO KIND
OF RELY ON THAT FRAMEWORK. AND
ABOUT THE TIME. AND THERE IS.
UNDER THAT WE BE PENNY FROM THE
BOY OF STATE COMMUNITY. RELATE
TO THE SECURE TREATMENT
FACILITIES. BUT THERE'S AN
ABILITY TO RELY ON EXISTING
REGULATIONS- IN THE NEAR TERM-
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BOARD OF
CKD CORRECTIONS NAME MODIFYING
THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND THERE
ARE CERTAIN TIME LINES AROUND.
AND THAT FACILITY FREE THAT
WOULD BE PENN FROM. THE BOY. IS
THAT TIMELY TO STEP THE C. FOR
ARE BECAUSE- OUT OF COURT TO
THE BILL IS IT CHILL FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT NOW I DON'T RECALL
THERE BEING A SPECIFIC DATE BY
WHICH COUNTIES NEED TO HAVE
SECURE EUSTACE TREATMENT
FACILITIES UP AND RUNNING.
ZACKS SOME OF THAT WOULD BE
DEPENDENT ON HOW THE CORDS
DETERMINE WITHIN THE IS KIND OF
INDIVIDUAL REHABILITATION PLANS
IN IN THAT USUAL PROCESS
PROCESS WHERE USERS. I SEE THE
END GOAL IS TO HIDE IF COUNTY
IS. NEED TO HAVE THIS TO HAVE
THEM IN. AS SOON AS POSSIBLE I
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING BUT I THINK
THAT THERE'S ANY SPECIFIC
TIMELINE WHICH COUNTIES NEED TO
HAVE THESE TREATMENT FACILITIES
IN PLACE. AND BY ACCIDENT IDEAS
THAT USE WOULD BE COMING TO
THEM ON JULY FIRST THAT MAY
REQUIRE THAT OF TREATMENT.
BERMAN IF I DO YOU HAVE AN DATE.
ACCORDING TO THE BILL IT'S JAN
A JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE UNLESS I'M WRONG. IS
THERE THAT A DAY. THAT AND
COUNTIES GONNA BE TO HAVE. TO
BUILD YOU THIS OR- AMOUNT BY
THE SPECIFIC DATE. I APOLOGIZE
HOW BEAUTIFUL UP WITH YOU
SENATOR GIRLS I'M NOT OF A BUT
DEEPER. TO BOARD AND THEY SAID
THEY THERE IS A REQUIREMENT
JULY TWENTY TWO THREE THE BOARD
OF STATE. KERR WOULD- REVIEW X.
STANDARDS AND CONSIDER
MODIFYING THEM AND THERE'S A
THERE'S A NUMBER OF TIME LINES
AROUND KIND OF ESTABLISHED AN
OFFENSE BEATS ME. I NOT AWARE
OF A PROVISION IN THE BILL AT
THIS POINT AS I SAY HERE THAT.
COUNTY TO A STEP. SECURE YOU
TREATMENT FACILITIES ON ANY
SPECIFIC TIME WHEN OTHER. THE
ON. FOR THE PURPOSES OF SERVING
ID WHICH ON JULY FIRST OF YEAR.
OKAY SO I GUESS THAT'S MY
BECAUSE THE WAY THAT READ THE
BILL OR THE BILL IS PRESENTED
TO US BEFORE US TODAY IT SAYS
THAT ACCORDING TO THE LANGUAGE
IT CONTINUES AND THAT THE- WE
HAVE TWO OR THE COUNTIES. HAVE
TO EITHER PROVIDE SECURE
FACILITIES BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE OR CONTRACT OUT
FOR THE SERVICES FOR THESE.
PARTICULAR USE- BUT IT ALSO
SAYS. WE NEED A CORRECTIONS HAS
UNTIL JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WHICH IS THE SAME DATE TO
ESTABLISH THE STANDARDS. SO I'M
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS THAT THE
COUNTY HAS A CONTRACT DAY TO
CONTRACT THEM OUT OR BUILD A
FACILITY THAT HOUSES THESE
INDIVIDUALS- THAT WERE SO BAD
THEY ACTUALLY GOT CARVED OUT OF
THIS BILL LAST YEAR AND- ON THE
SAME DATE SO YOU'RE EXPECTING
THE COUNTIES BASED ON THE BILL
LANGUAGE BEFORE US THAT. THESE
COUNTIES HAVE TO HAVE THE
SECURE FACILITIES UP AND
RUNNING BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE OR CONTRACT OUT.
AND THEN ALSO THE STANDARDS TO
OPERATE THOSE FACILITIES OR
BUILD THAT FACILITY OR TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THESE USE- DON'T
EVEN HAVE TO BE ESTABLISHED
UNTIL JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WHICH IS. THE EXACT SAME
DATE SO I'M NOT SURE HOW THIS
WORKS ON THE GROUND PER SE. I
UNDERSTAND I THINK I AM IF I
CAN JUST QUICKLY CLARIFY I
THINK THERE'S A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT COUNTIES
ARE GOING TO GO ABOUT
ESTABLISHING. SECURITY IS
TREATMENT FACILITIES I THINK
SENATOR GROVE IN YOUR EXAMPLE
YOU'RE ASSUMING A COUNTY WOULD
CONSTRUCT A BRAND NEW FACILITY
FROM THE GROUND UP TO MEET THAT
REQUIREMENT. THAT'S CERTAINLY
NOT WHAT'S REQUIRED IN THE
LEGISLATION THE LEGISLATION
SIMPLY ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK-
FOR HOW CAN YOU CAN OPERATE THE.
SECURE YOU FACILITIES.
COMPANIES HAVE THIS YEAR FOR
STRUCTURE THAT THERE SERVING
YOU THAT ARE. TO THE- AND- THE-
HOUSE NOT KIND OF RUN THE GAMUT
OF OR HOW DO. THAT RUN THE DAY.
AND OF THIS. THAT ARE BEING. SO
I SEE THAT. GOAL HERE TO
ESTABLISH THAT. TO ALLOW
COUNTIES FLAG. TO APPLY THAT
FOR WORK IN THE IN TWO. KIND
WHICH MEANS THAT THEY MAY OR
MAY NOT. TO CONSTRUCT NEW FOR.
IN THE NEAR TERM. THE BOARD
SEATING CAN YOU KERR. IS
REALIZE EXIST STAN THAT IT. FOR
JUVENILE. AND OTHER. YOUTH
FACILITIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING USED TO SERVE YOU WITH.
AND WITH THE IDEA THAT THERE
MIGHT BE MODIFICATIONS TO THOSE
STANDARDS AND SPECIFIC TO
SECURE YOUR TREATMENT
FACILITIES. BUT JUST. TO YOU
CAN OF REFLECTED BY AT IT IN.
IT MAY NOT BE EVERY COW IS
GOING CONSTRUCT BRAND FOR. TO
MEET THAT. THAT SYSTEM IN THE
BILL- I DON'T THAT THEY'RE
GONNA CA. BRAND NEW FACILITY
IT'S JUST AN OPTION IF THEY DO
BUT THEY- HAVE TO EITHER
CONTRACT OUT OR USE EXISTING
FACILITIES AND TO- TAKE IN.
THESE HIGH RISK VERY HIGH RISK
INCARCERATED USE. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT BOTHERED
ME ABOUT THE LANGUAGES OF THE
DATES WERE JUST SIMULTANEOUSLY
TO SOMETHING THAT I NOTICED SO-
THEY HAVE TO HAVE EITHER A NEW
FACILITY BUILT AN EXISTING
FACILITY MODIFIED. BY JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE BUT
YET THE STATE BOARD OF
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS ISN'T
EVEN GOING TO COME OUT WITHTHE
GUIDELINES. OR THE AND- AT THE
STANDARDS UNTIL JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO IT I
THINK ON THE GROUND IT MAKES IT
A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR COUNTIES
TO COMPLY AT ALL. THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE THOUGH ANOTHER
AGO WE FACED- A FEW YEARS AGO A
FEW YEARS BACK WHEN WE REDUCE
DJS AT AGE JURISDICTION- WELL.
WHEN WE TALKED EDUCATE ENTRY
PROVIDE THEY TOLD THAT THEY
REALLY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO EFFECTIVELY REHABILITATE THE
USE THAT THEY SERVE. AND THE
KIDS WERE LEAVING DJJ WITHOUT
FINISHING IN- PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE. JUST FOR EXAMPLE IF A
AB IF ONE OF THE EASIEST- WAS-
ASSIGNED OR REQUIRED TO ATTEND
A- AND A EIGHTEEN MONTH DRUG
TREATMENT PROGRAM OR IT. DID
YOU KNOW I THIRTEEN MEANT. AND
YOU KNOW DO. VIOLENCE
PROGRAMMERS YOU KNOW SOMETHING
LIKE THAT- AND BUT THEY WERE
ONLY IN THERE FOR LESS THAN A
YEAR HOW DID THEY COMPLETE THAT
PROGRAM IS THEIR RESOURCES. FOR
THE COUNTY TO BE ABLE TO.
COMPLETOS PROGRAM AND AFTER.
THEY LEAVE THE FACILITY OR IS
THAT GOING TO BE FIXED IN THIS
BILL AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THE QUESTION THAT'S NOT
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED IN THIS
BILL AND WE ARE PROVIDING
RESOURCES TO COUNTY IS TO SERVE
THE REALIGNED USE THAT WOULD
PRESUMABLY BE DURING THE PERIOD
OF THEIR INCARCERATION- BUT
DEFINITELY IN SPECIFICALLY IN
THIS LEGISLATION THAT
ADDRESSES. AND DESPITE THE
ISSUE THAT YOU FLAG. SO HOW HOW
ARE WE GOING TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THEIR REHABILITATION AND IF
IT'S IF THE RECOMMENDATION FROM
ALL THOSE INVOLVED. AND THINK
THAT THIS PARTICULAR YOUTH.
NEEDS EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF
TREATMENT OR FIFTEEN MONTHS OF
TREATMENT OR WHATEVER IT IS AND
THEIR THEIR ONE YEAR SO HOW DO
WE MEET THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR SUCCESSFUL REHABILITATION.
SURE AND I GUESS WE CAN ALL I.
MAKE AND BURST. CAN YOU
SPECIFIC REAL TO USE. AND SAID
REALLY DO THAT ARE ESSENTIALLY.
WITH THE LARGEST. AND. THE IN
TO BE A TO A C. YOUTH AS A
THERE HAS TO BE IN OF STUFF
THAT OUR TEAM THE HOUSE BE FINE
BY THE COURT THERE HAS TO BE IN
INDIVIDUAL REFILL. PLAN THAT'S
FOR. AND IN A BILL IT'S SORT OF
A FRAMER FOR THOUGHT AND IN THE
IN RE. PLAN PRESUME WHAT
DISCUSS IN THAT- IN ADDITION TO
A NUMBER OF IN THAT THIS
PROGRAMMING THAT BE FROM TO THE-
ANY KIND OF FORMULATE A PLAN.
PRESUMABLY THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE. VERY NICELY. OPERATION
APART AND ENDS WITH MULTI. PART
WOULD TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THE LENGTH OF THAT SENTENCE- IN
DETERMINING. HOW THE
REHABILITATION PLAN IS TO BE
KIND OF CONSTRUCTED OR ROLLED
OUT. AND JUST MY LAST QUESTION
M. I KNOW IT'S IN THE ADULT
FACILITIES BUT IS THE PLOT TECH
COURT CASE- DOES IT HAVE ANY
JURISDICTION OVER MOVING THESE
YOUTH FROM FACILITY TO FACILITY
OR TRANSITIONING THEM I NO
WONDER THAT PLOT A COURT CASE
THAT WE DISCUSSED YESTERDAY
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. THAT
THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED TO DO
INTAKE ANYMOREAT THE ADULT
PENITENTIARIES AND THEN THEY
ALSO COULD NOT MOVE INMATES
FROM ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER DOES
THIS AFFECT- THESE- HEAVILY
INCARCERATED OR USE AS WELL.
APOLOGY SENATOR GROVE I NOT
ABLE TO RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION BUT HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOUR OFFICE. YOU I'M AWARE
OF THAT AYE AYES AYE AYES HERE
BUT TO- UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR AND MICHAEL I. IT. WHEN YOU
SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER HANDS
UP- BEFORE I CALL AND A SENATOR
NIELSEN AGAIN SOON MAKE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS- HEY MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST COUNTIES
AND YOU CAN GET THIS DATA.
FROM- FROM DJJ OR FROM AT PSEC
BUT MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST COUNTIES HALF FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS FOR CLOSE TO
TEN YEARS NOW BEEN SENDING. NO
OR FEWER THAN FORTY FIVE USED
TO OUR STATE DJJ FACILITIES AND
LIKE I SAID THAT TREND HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR ABOUT A DECADE. IN
TWO DAYS THE POPULATION IN OUR
DJ STATE RUN FACILITIES IS
ABUSED IS ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
DOWN FROM A HIGH OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED. JUST A DECADE AGO FOR
TO IT YESTERDAY TO GO. AND THE
LENGTH OF STAY IN DJJ IS THREE
YEARS NO ONE GOES IN JUST FOR
ONE YEAR BUT- BECAUSE OF THE
DUE TO THE- ACTION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. TO SIGNAL THAT WE
ARE CLOSING THOSE STATE
FACILITIES AND WE DID SO LAST
YEAR. D. BY THE TIME THAT DJJ
ACTUALLY CLOSES THERE WILL BE
FAR FEWER YOUTH JUST ON THE
NATURAL SO WHILE THERE WILL BE
USED THAT COUNTIES WILL HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR- AND THOSE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
SENDING YOUTH TO DJJ FACILITIES
WILL. IN CAN'T SPEAK FOR THEM
BUT IN MANY CASES WILL BE
HANDLING- THE YOUTH AS THEY
HAVE BEEN FOR THE LAST YOU KNOW
FIVE SIX YEARS AND THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN RELYING ON THE DJJ
FACILITIES WILL. PRIMARILY NOT
ONLY BUT PRIMARILY HAVE NEW
YOUTH OFFENDERS TO DEAL WITH
RATHER THAN SO MANY THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HOUSED ON AND THEN
JUST TO ANOTHER- CLARIFICATION.
CASE DOES NOT COVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
JUSTICE. ON SENATE NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MADAM FOR A SECOND TO
OPERATE AND I WILL BE BRIEF.
IT'S COME TO MIND. THAT WE HAVE
A LEGAL PROBLEM HERE WE DON'T
THE COUNTIES TO. WHAT THE LAST
ADULT REALIGNMENT OCCURRED
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. IN THE NEXT
BUDGET THEREAFTER THE NEXT TO
ACTUALLY I ASKED THE SECRETARY
OF THE DOLPHINS OF CORRECTIONS
AGENCY I SAID YOU KNOW- DEALING
WITH HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FEWER. INMATES AND PAROLEES.
GET YOUR BUDGET HAS GONE UP.
FOR YEARS THE HUE AND CRY WAS
WE SHOULD TAKE THAT MONEY AND
GIVE IT TO THE HIGHER EDUCATION.
AS IF THERE WOULD BE A BIG
DIVIDEND FOR REALIGNMENT. THERE
WAS INTACT AS A SET COSTS WENT
UP. WHAT WAS HIS RESPONSE THE
COURT. INDEED THE COURTS HAVE
HAD A HUGE IMPACT OF FEDERAL
RECEIVER. CALLING THE SHOTS THE
ADULT SYSTEM. WELL AT THE TIME
I SUGGESTED TO THE CELTICS
THOSE SAME INMATE LAWSUITS THAT
ARE SO PLAGUE AND COST DEARLY.
THE TREASURER OF THE STATE ARE
GOING TO MORE RIGHT IN YOUR J.
AS THEY HAVE. NOW THERE'S A
WHOLE NEW THEIR- OF LAW THAT
WOULD ON THE GOT. I DO NOT
THINK THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS GOING TO MAKE THOSE COUNTIES
HOLE FOR THE DECISION THE STATE
MADE THAT IS OBLIGED THEM AND
MADE THEM VULNERABLE TO THE
LAWSUIT. I ASK THE QUESTION
WHERE IS SHE SAID ON THIS. END
OF THE NIGHT HERE COMPLAINING
ABOUT IT. I DON'T WANT TO HEAR
FROM THEM IN THE FUTURE. RIGHT
SEEING NO OTHER HANDS A POST
SORRY SENATOR STERN YOU HAVE
YOUR HAND UP GO AHEAD SENATOR
STORY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SORRY FOR YEAH- ADD ME THROW MY
HAND DOWN- CANNOT CAN I JUST
ASK ONE POINT OF CLARIFICATION-
EXCITED ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL IN
THE CLEAN UP AND ESPECIALLY IF
THE FOCUS ON. TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE HERE AND THAT THE
FLEXIBILITIES THAT IS
LEGISLATION TO AUTHORIZE IT TO
THE POINT THAT I'M SURE YOU
WERE MAKING AN ADMINISTRATION
WHICH IS MAKING ABOUT. NOT JUST
CONSTRUCTING NEW STANDALONE
FACILITIES BUT ALSO DOING
CREATIVE WORK AND- YOU KNOW
PROBATION CAMPS OR RANCHES OR
OTHER SITES AROUND THE STATE
RIGHT NOW AT LEAST IN LA AND
VENTURA COUNTY WE'VE GOT SOME.
REALLY INSPIRING WORK THAT
HAPPENS BUT YOU KNOW- A MIX OF
FACILITY TYPE SO I LOVE THE
FRAMEWORK HERE- MY QUESTION I
GUESS DOVE TAILS ON SENATOR
GROWS QUESTION- WHICH WHICH
ABOUT WHICH REALLY GETS TO MISS
YOU ITS POINT ABOUT THE- THE
REHABILITATION PLAN AND HOW
THAT BASELINE TERMS ESTABLISHED.
BY THE BY THE COURTS SO- I WANT
TO KNOW ABOUT HOW. THE IS THAT
WE'VE ALL- PREVIOUSLY AND- WHAT
KIND OF FLEX IT EASE THIS CLEAN
UP GIVES. IT MAYBE IT ON THE
CALLS ISSUED LOOK AT BUT IN MY
EXPERIENCE YOU KNOW WORKING IN
THE MAX UNITS AT ALAMEDA COUNTY.
EARLY ON IN MY LONG CAREER IN
IN IN UNITS WHERE THERE WAS NO
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT SUPPORT
FOR THESE YOUNG PEOPLE. AND YOU
KNOW IT WAS A VERY
INCARCERATION ORIENTED.
OPERATION AND REALLY SORT OF
EXACERBATED TRAUMA BUT- IT TO
THE POINT ABOUT. THE BASELINE
SOMETIMES THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
NEED LONGER TERM- SERVICES- AND
YOU KNOW TO JUST CUT THEM OFF
WHEN THEY'RE OUT AWARD SHIP AND
SAY YOU'RE GOOD- OFTEN DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE THE UNDERLYING ISSUES
THAT THEY'RE FACING- AND SOME
OF THOSE MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES REQUIRE SORT OF ON
GOING. SUPPORT EVEN BEYOND THAT
PERIOD OF- OF EITHER DETENTION
OR WARSHIP OR WHATEVER MAY BE
SO I'M JUST WONDERING HOW. IS
EVERYTHING IS THE DOES THE
MONEY CUT OFF WHEN THE BASELINE
TERM CUTS OFF OR IS THERE ANY
FLEXIBILITY IN SORT OF
UNDERLYING LAW OR IN THIS BILL
THAT ALLOWS FOR. THAT KIND OF
ONGOING SUPPORT SERVICE- IT'S
NOT REENTRY IS NOT THE RIGHT
TERM BUT THAT THAT KIND OF
ONGOING CARE AND IT DOESN'T
JUST HAVE TO BE MENTAL HEALTH.
IS THAT REALLY NOT AT A
DIFFERENT PART OF FUNDING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE THIS MONEY
REALLY HAPPY IS FOCUSED ONLY ON
THE FACILITY OR- THE DURING
DURING THAT PERIOD OF THE
BASELINE. OR MODIFIED BASELINE
THAT THAT'S MY QUESTION JUST
SEEING HOW MUCH FLEXIBILITY WE
GOT. BERMAN FINANCED YOU WANNA
ADDRESS THAT. HI ALISON HEWITT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANKS
FOR YOUR QUESTION SENATOR STERN
AND IF I CAN JUST HELP CLARIFY
SO WHEN I SPEAK TO THREE LAST
YEAR WE INCLUDED.
APPROPRIATIONS EACH YEAR TO THE
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THE REAL LINES YOUTH AND THERE
IS NO SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS ON
NOT FINDING IT WOULD SAY OTHER
THAN THAT THAT FUNDING IS
DESIGNED FOR COUNTIES PROVIDE
KIND OF APPROPRIATE REAL BILL
ME REHABILITATIVE AND
SUPERVISORY SERVICES TO THE
YOUTH AND COUNTIES ARE GOING AT
THE HOUSE LOOKS TO IN TERMS OF
HOW TO DATE. AB ACCOMPLISHED
AND SO DOES APPROPRIATE ARE
THERE IS APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PER USE THAN THE GOAL
THERE IS A REALLY ASSET
COUNTIES UP FOR SUCCESS IN
TERMS OF- PROVIDING KIND OF
SERVICES TO USE TO MEET THEIR
KIND UNIQUE NEEDS AND I ACROSS
THE BOARD AND- IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING SERVICES AFTER A U.
S. LEAVES THAT. LEAVES THAT
COUNTY FACILITY I'M I THAT
THERE'S A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT MIGHT BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO BETTER TO NOT
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY A
SPECIFIC FOCUS OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THERE SOME.
PROPOSED THAT THE-
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN KIND OF
LOOKING AT- IN OF TRYING.
FACILITATE MORE HAND OFFS AND
BIGGER THAN JUST OUT BY
JUVENILES BY FOR ADULTS AS WELL.
I'M SO THAT THERE CAN BE
CONTINUE CARE BUT MY-
EXPERIENCE THAT. AYE COLLEAGUES
ON THE AND HUMAN SERVICES. I
SIDE OF THE HOUSE WOULD BE.
BETTER EXPERTS IN THEIR EIGHT
TO X. THE- AT KIND OF LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER THAT YOU THE
RELEASED IN TERMS OF. TO FOR.
WARM HAND OR OTHER. AND SENATOR
STERN MAJOR ADD THAT THERE IS
ON GOING. THROUGH THE USE
OFFENDER BLOCK. AND TWENTY- I
REALIZE- PUBLIC SAFETY. BUCKET
SO THAT SOMETHING THAT I'M
GOING. SENATOR STERN- I SEE THE-
L. A. O. LOO CHRIS MORROW ALSO
IS HAND UP I'M NOT SURE IF HE-
IS A- CAN ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION
BUT IF- IF YOU'RE OKAY ALL CALL
ON HIM AND THEN I CAN GIVE YOU
BACK THE- PEACE. HAVE THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY MR CHRIS MORROW.
MAKER'S MARK THAT A- YEAH I'M
GOING TO WRITE YOUR LEFT THE
REST- SURGICAL WELL A COUPLE
QUESTIONS KEEP OUT EARLIER. SO
ON SENATOR GUARDS. JOURNALISM.
BERMAN MY NEEDS. IT WAS CORRECT
THAT THE FUNDING IS A- TWO ONE
FIFTY DOLLARS DOLLARS PER YOU
IN TERMS HOW STRUCTURED IN A
SPEECH WHEN THREE- IT'S NOT
DESIGN. THERE ARE CERTAIN
RESTRICTIONS AND REQUIREMENTS
ON HOW TO USE ONE OF THOSE THAT
COUNTY MUST COME UP WITH A- FOR
HOW TO USE FUND- ONE OF THE- OF.
THAT USE THE MONEY FOR. WOULD
BE ABLE. SERVICE INCLUDING
PLANNING NEEDS OF. SERVICES
ACTUALLY FINDING HOUSE AND
THINGS TO DO IN THAT YOU CAN-
SO THAT COULD. BE A EXACTLY YOU
OF THE- THAT'S THE- AND HE'S
TRYING TO GET A. TO PROTECT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR OF HOW.
AFTER. WOULD HAVE A PLACE IN
DATA ON THE NON SUPERVISION.
INDIVIDUAL TO- A UC SECURITY
TREATMENT FACILITY AND FRANKLIN
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE EITHER THROUGH THEIR
OWN FACILITY OR BY CONTRACTING.
BUT IT DOESN'T CREATE A MANDATE
THAT COUNTIES MUST PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE OR MUST FACE THEIR OWN
SERVICE. BUT ARE WE DISABILITY
FROM THIS. THE FOR UP IT IS A
APPLY. TO THE INDIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN DID YOU
HAVE ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT OUT.
NO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
THANK YOU TO THE MINISTRATION
GREAT. RIGHT SO I THINK I'M
GONNA MOVE TO- PUBLIC COMMENT
NOW. RIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THIS HEARING ROOM.
THIRDS HERE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE LET ME LOOK AT OUR-
ALTERNATE ROOM. AND THERE IS NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE EITHER
SO WE WILL QUEUE UP MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES.
AND ALLOW THOSE WHO ARE CALLING
IN TO TESTIFY WE'LL START WITH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB
EIGHTY SEVEN. AND AGAIN I LET
ME JUST QUICKLY READ THAT PHONE
NUMBER. THAT PHONE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT NINE THREE SEVEN
THREE FOUR THREE MODERATOR GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THOSE WHO YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN THERE ARE AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE TO DO AT
THIS TIME TO EXPRESS HIS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. WE HAVE
ONE PERSON WHO'S- WHO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK GO
AHEAD. ONE TWENTY NINE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WELL WE OPPOSED SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE AM EST DJJ REALIGNMENT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ACCURATE TO
TAKE A VERY IMPORTANT NEW
RESPONSIBILITY ITH THIS
REALIGNMENT AND WE ARE NOW
FOCUSED ON IMPLEMENTATION. WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE IS
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF UNDERSTANDING LOCAL NEEDS TO
CARRY OUT THIS RESPONSIBILITY.
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP ASPECT THAT
THE EIGHTY EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH
IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF COUNTY
TO IMPLEMENT DJJ REALIGNMENT.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THERE IT
CONTINUED WORK WE CAN DO
TOGETHER TO STRENGTHEN
IMPLEMENTATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO TRYING TO BUILD A
PARTNERSHIP. LASTLY WE BELIEVE
THE SECURE YOU TREATMENT
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN EIGHTY
EIGHTY SEVEN REPRESENTS A
REASONABLE STRUCTURE AND WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE TIME AND
ENERGY THAT ALL PARTIES
INVESTED IN GETTING THIS DONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MODERATOR
THERE ANY LINE CALLERS. BLIND
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHEAP PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IN ORDER TO BE
TO IMPLEMENT THE POLICY ENACTED
LAST YEAR BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR TO REALIGN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SSTEM TO
COUNTY. THE PROVISION THAT
EIGHTY EIGHTY SEVEN SUCH AS THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SECURE TRACK
AND ADDED CLEAR G. TO AVOID NET
MIGHT NEED OR CREATING A DAHLE
HIGHLY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THIS
OPTIONS ALSO VERY TIMELY- TO
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION LIGHT OF
THE PINE LANE PLAYED OUT. I
THINK SEVERAL OF THE COMMENTS
IS YOUR TODAY REFLECT THE MANY
IMPORTANT ISSUES WE WILL NEED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STATE ON TO ADDRESS THE COMPLEX
NEED TO BE VIEWED WE CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. WE APPRECIATE
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK
AND ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK TOGETHER. TO FURTHER
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION THANK
YOU. ANY OTHERS MODERATOR. AND
I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE L. TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
GREAT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. BOETTICHER THERE IS
NO NEWS BUT THEY WISH TO. AXLE
SO LET'S IT BACK TO- YEAH
COMMITTEE ON. THERE'S NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CAN WE
HAVE A MOTION ON AB EIGHTY
SEVEN. ALL RIGHTS BEEN MOVED-
BY SENATOR EGGMAN THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS. MISTER STOPPING
SHORT COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB EIGHTY SEVEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
YES AND NO CABALLERO. COURTESY
WHAT DOES THE I. DALI. THE RAZA
THE RUSSELL I EGGMAN. EGGMAN
HIGH GROWTH. GROVE NO KAMLAGER.
LAYERED. LOOK I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
MAN. MAN I NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE. I'M SORRY FOR
TROUBLE NOW THE TROUBLE NO. PAN
PAN HI STERN. STERN TURN AYE
STERN AYE.LIKE OWSKI HI BY
KELSEY I. TWELVE THE THREE- THE
BILL HAS- TWELVE FIVE VOTES
THREE NO THERE WERE A FEW
MISSING MEMBERS- ALL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN TO SEE IF ARE MISSING
MEMBERS FIVE RETURN- I THINK IT
WAS MISS CABALLERO MISTER DALI
IN THIS CALM WATER- OTHERWISE-
MEMBERS- WE'LL JUST GIVE IT A
FEW MINUTES TO SEE IF THEY CAN
RETURN BUT OTHERWISE WE WILL
HAVE WE WILL THEN CONCLUDE OUR
BUSINESS. SO THE ROLE IS STILL
OPEN.
FIVE ARE- THE ROLE IS
STILL OPEN FOR AB EIGHTY SEVEN
HOWEVER I JUST WANT TO MAKE ACORRECTION I STATED THE ACCOUNT
NUMBER INCORRECTLY THE COUNT SO
FAR IS ELEVEN YES VOTES FOR NO
VOTES AND- WE HAVE SENATOR COM
ORDER HERE BUT WERE AWAITING A
SENATOR CAFIERO AND SENATOR
DOLLY UNLESS WE GET A WORD THAT
THEY ARE CUT OFF SENATOR DOLLY
IS HERE- ALL RIGHT SO WHY
DON'T- MISTER STOP AND SHOP
WHAT A JOKE IN THE ROLE SO AT
LEAST THOSE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
RETURNED TO CAN ADD ON IF THEY
SO CHOOSE. AB EIGHTY SEVEN
MOTIONS TO PASS SENATORS
CABALLERO. DALI DALI NO CALM
WATER KAMAGRA HIGH. ALL RIGHT
THE BILL IS STILL ON CALL THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TWELVE FIVE.
BUT. NO RESPONSE YET. YEAH.
FIFTY A. R. BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE IS GOING TO
TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS-
WHILE WE WERE OUR ROLE IS STILL
OPEN FOR AB EIGHTY SEVEN BUT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE RECESS THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILL I'M NOT BE ADDING
ON SO WE CAN CLOSE. WE CAN LIFT
THE CALL. AND CONSULTANT CAN
YOU- CALL THE ROLL ONE MORE
TIME THAT WAY I CAN THEN. CLOSE
THE ROLE AND ANNOUNCED THAT THE
BILL IS OUT SO THIS IS FINE AB
EIGHTY SEVEN THE TRAILER BILL
CLEAN UP FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT.
A. B. A. SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS
CENTER CABALLERO. PFIZER MISTER
CONSULTING THE FINAL- VOTE
COUNT ON THAT BILL IS. TWELVE
TO FIVE SO THE- AB EIGHTY SEVEN
PASSES TWELVE YES VOTES FIVE NO
VOTES AND WITH THAT WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE FINE AB EIGHTY
SEVEN AND THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW WILL
NOW INCLUDE. A JUROR.